دعت وزاره الدفاع السودانيه متقاعد القوات
المسلحه من ضباط وضباط صف وجنود للتوجه
الى اقرب قياده عسكريه لتسليحهم تامين
لانفسهم وحرماتهم وجيرانهم وحمايه
لاعراضهم والعمل وفق خططي هذه المناطق حسب
تعبير البيان اضافت وزاره الدفاع
السودانيه انما وصفتهم بقوات التمرد تمادت
في اذلال رموز الدوله من الادباء
والصحفيين والقضاه والاطباء فضلا عن اسر
ومطارده متقاعدي القوات النظاميه والقبض
عليهم
ياتي ذلك بينما يسود هدوء حذر جبهات
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في العاصمه السودانيه بعد يوم من
الاشتباكات التي وصفت بانها الاعنف خلال
هدنه الايام السبعه
وشهدت ولاياته جنوب وغرب دارفور وشمال
كردفان غربيه السودان هدوءا مماثله وفي
الاحياء القريبه من مناطق القتال خلت
الشوارع من الحركه بينما تدافع الناس في
مناطق اخرى للاستفاده من الهدنه لشراء
احتياجاتهم وحاول بعض التجار نقل بضائعهم
الى اماكن اكثر امنا
كما افاد مراسلنا بسماع اطلاق نار متقطع
في جنوب غربي ام درمان وكان حساب الجيش
السوداني عبر فيسبوك قد نشر فيديو قال انه
يوثق المواجهات والاشتباكات المباشره مع
قوات الدعم السريع في ام درمان يوم امس
الخميس وتظهر اللقطات المصوره جنودا من
الجيش السوداني في اشتباك بالاسلحه
الخفيفه داخل احد الشوارع الرئيسيه في
منطقه السلاح المهندسين
هذا وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان السعوديه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاحظتا في
بيان مشترك تحسنا ملحوظا فاحترام اتفاقيه
وقفه اطلاق النار قصير الامد والترتيبات
الانسانيه في السودان يوم امس الخميس قال
البيان انه بغض النظر عن رصد استخدام
طائرات عسكريه واطلاق نار متقطع في
الخرطوم فقد تحسن الوضع اضاف البيان ان
الرياض وواشنطن تواصلتا مع طرفي النزاع
بعد الانتهاكات ولفتتا الى ان تجدد القتال
عرضا المدنيين للخطر واعاق المساعدات
الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه ما
قوض الاهداف الرئيسيه لوقف اطلاق النار
كما حذر البيان الطرفين من مزيد من
الانتهاكات وناشدهما تحسين احترام اتفاقيه
وقف اطلاق النار وهو ما طبقه الطرفان
بالفعل وفق البيان الذي دعا الطرفين الى
التقيد بالتزاماتهما بموجب اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار بوضع احتياجات الشعب السوداني
في المقام الاول والالتزام بالشروط التي
اتفقا عليها قبل عده ايام في جده السعوديه